- So Brooke, you created a
platform for women over 40
starting new chapters,
which I think is fantastic.
- It is called, "Beginning Is Now,"
and I really just, especially
during COVID I thought,
I'm 56, right?
But I feel stronger, I feel more powerful,
I feel more confident.
I don't feel as insecure.
- I feel like it happens with age.
- Yeah.
- And that's the part to me
that's so amazing.
But when you're over 40 and
you look at what's out there,
we're not marketed to.
- I don't know.
- But there's not a lot of
like movies or TV shows,
it's usually like a specific
like younger, or then older.
It's like there's nothing generally
in that gap for like a lot of us.
- It's like 20's or Helen
Mirren and she's gorgeous, but.
- Yeah, oh my God, I hate her.
Like who looks like that?
- I think one of the
things is though, too,
I feel like I'm at this age too,
as an actress where I'm like,
do I just age nicely?
Or like, I think I just got to get old
so that I can keep with
having good parts too.
Like I kind of have to just like,
not fall for the praise of Los Angeles
and just kind of age normally.
- You're doing a beautiful job of it.
(audience applauding)
- I keep working though.
I feel like to get interesting
parts, you know what I mean?
- It is it's a hard thing
and I've talked to a lot of,
you know, I never had that
conversation with actors,
it's always actresses.
And it's always, 'cause
there's a harder thing
that's always put on women.
- Yeah how it like, yeah.
- Netflix was really.
- And how natural can I age?
- Well, you just don't want
half your conversation about your part,
like the supporting
conversation to be like,
oh, what face work did she do?
You know what I mean?
Which would be devastating.
- Is that a real?
- Oh yes.
Well Netflix, when they
originally talked to me about it,
it was a woman who in this
one particular division said,
we are interested in
women over a certain age,
over 40, they're saying,
because they're empowered women
and she said, that's what
we're gearing towards.
So, it's really, it's lovely
that to hear a network
say that that's their focus, you know,
and it's a section of Netflix,
you know, but it is,
and that's what she wants
to do, this executive.
And I was so happy that, you know,
they weren't trying to make me 30.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, I was my age and I was
acting my age and in myself,
and really just there's
pride in it and I love that
there's starting to be
representation like that
at least in these movies.
- And as a woman that's about
to be 40, I love watching it.
Like, I don't really relate,
sorry, anymore to a lot of the younger,
you know what I'm saying?
There should be like
sections for all of us,
we like to watch different
things, and maybe people,
I don't know our own age
doing stuff, so yeah.
- And there's romance and
there's humor and there's
it's parts of it that are
sort of just sexy enough,
you know what I mean?
But it's, presenting women
with all of their facets,
and I think that that's,
it took me decades to grow into myself
and not compare myself or say,
oh God, they want me to do this,
or I'm not this enough,
or I'm not that enough.
- The reason why you
probably did that though,
is 'cause people put that
on us when we're young.
- They do, especially,
yeah, are you kidding me?
Of course, all of us had
different versions of that.
You probably had it the
worst Brooke, right?
- I mean, there was no
social media when I was.
- That's true.
- I mean it was, I had
my own set of different
things that I had to grapple
with insecurity wise,
but it was, you know, I was
called a face of a decade.
It's like.
- And that's a lot of pressure.
- Who decides that?
- Feel free to call mine
the face of the decade.
I don't know who decides, but no,
that's a lot of pressure.
- The arbitrary ridiculousness of it.
So what I did was became the class clown,
self-deprecate.
- Oh me too.
- Oh look at me, look at me.
And I need to diffuse the air,
I need to have not be
threatening to women.
I need to.
- Oh my God, that's how I
feel sometimes too yeah.
- And then you start to believe it,
then you start living in
your comments about yourself
and your self-deprecation and
that's not healthy either.
And so it's about finding
that balance of saying,
you know, I mean, by
virtue of getting older,
I would be considered a disappointment
because I would have had
to have died when I was 18
or something like that,
it's not funny, but like
to preserve what everybody has
on their psyche about me.
- Their perception.
Because at the end of the day,
sometimes people view you as a product
and not the actual person,
so they just see one thing.
Yeah, totally.
- And so I had to, throughout my life,
really just reveal myself
emotionally and in all ways
so that, that's what I could own.
So it wasn't just.
- I feel the same, like
same in a different way too.
Yeah, I was lucky working
with Sofia Coppola
at such a young age,
because at 16, when you don't
feel good about yourself,
she made me feel beautiful
so I had that to kind of take me through
the more masculine,
energy films and things,
I didn't look to anybody
or dress in a certain way
on the carpet that like
I had to be sexy,
I dressed the way I wanted to dress.
- That's a beautiful thing
to have that influence though
from a woman.
- I got lucky that I had
that at such a young age.
- And I never had that,
and I had male directors.
- Oh my God,
I had a photographer literally,
we might edit this out.
I had a photographer literally look at me
it was literally right
after "American Idol"
and it was like 20 years
ago and he was like, man,
you would be so pretty
if you lost 20 pounds
and I was like, oh my God,
how much weight do you
think you need to lose
to be attractive?
- Awesome that you said that.
- I love that.
(audience applauding)